a lot of times when people try to take a
successful TV show and make a movie out
of it the number one complaint is that
just seems like a longer version of an
episode but with duck tales it kind of
makes sense because every episode was
kind of like a mini movie so why not
make an actual movie out of it in this
case it definitely pays off and it's
kind of a shame it doesn't get more
attention than it deserves it's funny
because this came out near the same time
as the rescuers down under another
adventurous Disney film that doesn't get
enough attention it has all the great
animation the characters you remember a
lot of great action a few good jokes
it's an enjoyable family film scrooge
mcduck and the gang are on the search
for the treasure of collie Baba get it
but their tour guide named Deshawn is
working for an evil sorcerer named
Merlin played by Christopher Lloyd's
thus keep searching hunt outside hey he
knows that the real treasure of collie
Baba lies in this magic lamp and that
with his magic talisman that can turn
him into any animal can combine it with
the lamp to get unlimited wishes the
lamp however falls out of his hands and
instead into the hands of Huey Dewey
Louie and webby who discovered the crazy
genie inside played by Rick Taylor he's
a knee and goofy of course and befriends
the kids very quickly once Scrooge
discovers say he uses it of course for
greedy means and while being chased down
by the evil sorcerer he discovers what
truly matters and blah blah blah action
learning a lesson all that good stuff
okay so there's no groundbreaking morals
there to be learned here but that's not
what duck tales was all about in fact
duck tales wasn't even as much about
action as it was adventure and this is a
really enjoyable adventure I feel like
all the characters we've grown to love
get the proper amount of screen time
that they deserve Christopher Lloyd is
menacing of course as the villain Andrew
Taylor is an adequate genie I do feel
bad because shortly after a much funnier
disney genie would pop about that nobody
could really compete with but for
something that's more focused on kids
and family and not really adult jokes I
think he works okay it's fine because
the animation on the show was already
pretty impressive so they had to up it
even more for the movie and it really
looks good the only thing that might
raise a few eyebrows is the care
Dijon I don't know is this an offensive
character now yes I was just no needy
back then nobody thought twice about but
nowadays the people sensitivities I'm
not sure this could be taken the wrong
way or not I mean he does have a thick
accent and he is a thief I personally
never thought they were saying anything
about an entire race but maybe that's
why you never got such a major DVD
release oh no he's fine by me but some
people might take in a different way
like I said before it's just one big
DuckTales episode but we all really like
the ducktales episodes and what they had
to give us and here it is on a grand
scale I'd be lying if I said it was as
good as the original few episodes that
were tied together in the beginning but
hey we're doing a movie now and you
gotta play by movie rules and foreplay
by movie rules I think this film does
really well and it's entertaining and
it's engaging does it have a ton of
adult stuff not especially I'd say it's
more family-oriented but there's nothing
wrong with that it's done well it's done
creatively and it's a whole lot of fun
so if you like the show growing up or
you're a big fan of adventure this is
definitely one to check out
you